有句话叫短线靠等待
中线靠忍耐
长线靠真爱
但更多的时候我们遇到的问题是
不想等待
无法忍耐
只有真爱
最后靠着这点真爱
买了年筒油和四大行
还有很多人认为做短线
那就是老兽性吃皮霜
真嫌自己活得长
因为他们认为周期越短
市面上的酿化机构优势就越大
他们认为人力是很难跟酿化机构去抢肉吃的
这话说的好像是没错
但新闻认为不应该是这个样子的
如果你有幸刷到这个视频
请你一定要看完
这将颠覆你对交易
尤其是超短线交易的认知
首先我们买入一只股票
我们最大的期望是什么
最大的期望就是买入
它马上就开始涨
那么我们就要来分析一下
买入即涨这个词语
它要求的实际上是交易兑现的及时性
也就是说现在买入的一只股票
它等会儿得是上涨的
或者说它至少明天得是上涨的
也就说明了这种操作
它的预期是一个超短线的预期
但是我们一般做技术分析的方法是什么
是看日线分析对吧
看日线分析的时候
你会发现一个问题
问题就是它的最小周期的平均成本统计
是按五天来计算的
也就是说这种统计方法
它实际上是一个短线的统计方法
所以现在就很明白了
我们一直都是在用一个短线的分析方式
想去实现一个超短线的盈利预期
那么这当中就会有时间的鸿沟
最终我们就会发现
指标它是严重落后的
然后就会陷入预期经常不能兑现的尴尬局面
最直观的表现
就是我本来想玩个超短线
结果短线变长线
长线变共线
那么它的根本原因就在于分析方法和想要的结果
它是不匹配的
这中间它是一个不等于号
那么找到原因之后
我们就要从原因出发
从底层改变我们一贯的操盘方法
最终大家就会发现交易其实是挺简单的
那么我们应该怎么去改变呢
这就是本期视频要和大家讲到的双10操盘法
首先我们的第一步就是把旁边上面的K线图
从日线调成60分钟线
这是第一个60
因为它一天的交易是4个小时
一般短线的交易持股周期
最科学的应该是在五天左右
那么这就和活跃资金的交易习惯是相匹配的
一天四个小时
把它调成六十分钟线之后
相当于把一天分成了四块
这是第一步
那么第二步
就是我们要保留五日
十日
六十日是三条均线
它在日线图上面叫六十日均线
五日均线
十日均线
到了六十分钟的K线图上面
那么它就变成了六十小时线
还有五小时线
还有十小时线
那我们在旁边上就除了这三根线之外
其他的全部都隐藏掉
而且这个60小时
5小时
还有10小时的均线
它反映出来的平均成本
实际上是非常灵敏的
基本上可以避免均线系统所带来的滞后性
比如这个5小时均线和10小时均线
他们形成了一个死差
因为这一个交易是4个小时
也就是说它会画出4根线出来
画出4根k线
可能当天它这个死差就会形成了但是你要放到日线层面上去这当天还不一定能够形成这个死差可能要过两天它才能收出来所以我们如果参考这边的一个依据去做交易的话
实际上就会非常的及时
因为只跌了一天它就出现死差
出现死差之后
我们卖出或者说止盈
它就会非常非常及时
不会说出现跌了两三天
然后再出现这个卖出信号
再卖出的时候
我们可能已经被侵蚀一部分利润了
或者直接就是亏损
那么还有一些朋友不知道这点
不应该要怎么去设置
怎么去操作
钱不要滑走
等会打开交易软件教大家怎么去设置
那大家给我点个赞
接下来重点给大家讲一下这个方法应该怎么去用
其实方法非常简单
但很多人的特点就是喜欢把简单的事情越做越复杂
而高手从来都是划分为减
这个方法只需要三个信号
就可以让我们比较精准的完成一笔交易
第一个信号
那就是看到60分钟K线图上面的60小时均线
它是拐头向上的
我们这样才去关注这只股票
如果说它的60小时均线是向下的
说明这只股票差不多跌了有半个多月了
60个小时
一天是4个小时
差不多就是12天
那么这个股票就没有必要去关注了
这样它可能在日K线的层面上
已经形成了比较明显的下跌趋势
那么第二个信号就是买入信号
当股价突破60小时
或者回踩60小时均线的时候
那么我们就可以买入
这说明这个票它是在上涨趋势当中
而且还有所突破
或者说近半个月它是一个上涨趋势
但是最近两天有调整
调整之后再次往上攻
那么此时来讲的话
这都是一个比较好的买点
第三个信号那就是卖出信号
我们应该要在什么时候卖出呢
也就是说5小时均线和10小时均线形成死差的时候
这个时候我们就应该要去止盈
刚才也跟大家讲到了
两根均线在K线图上面形成一个死差
这个股价可能才跌了一天
此时如果决定止盈的话
你的利润可能并没有回吐多少
可以说是非常及时
避免了我们从日K线图上面去分析
它跌了两三天
然后再出现这个卖出信号
那么利润已经回吐很多了
那这个时候就是有滞后性的
当然任何方法它都不是万能的
我们要敢于在操作中出现失误的时候
承认自己的错误
并且及时止损
另外一个信号
那就是卖出信号
也就是说止损信号
当股价跌破60日均线的时候
我们要及时止损
卖出
这就是我们讲到的
用双六零操盘数需要注意的卖出信号
一个是5小时均线和10小时均线出现死差
另一个是跌破60小时的均线
好
接下来我们就打开交易软件
跟大家看一下这个方法
在实际操作中到底能不能实现有效的盈利
好 那我们现在首先第一步我们的双60这样发生什么
第一步那就是这个60分钟
我们只需要点击鼠标的左键点击OK
好 那么它就变成60分钟的一个周期的K向走势
好 第二步那么就是设置我们均线的这个仓数
设置均线仓数也很简单
只需要点击鼠标右键
点击鼠标右键之后就会出现这个东西
我们继续往下面找
直到找到这个设置技术指标仓数
这个MI仓数
好 找到之后我们点击它
点开了一个之后我们的第三步
那么就是把20 30 120 250把这线移动平均线全部隐藏掉点击确定我们这个整个就OK了整个OK之后我们来石盘测试一下这个账法在盘面上到底好不好用
这个也很简单
我们来找我们的交易机会
前面这一段
它一直都是在60小时均线的下方运行
那就没有构成我们的交易机会
那么到了这个位置
这个位置它出现了站稳
但是马上被跌破了
这也不是我们的交易机会
到了这个地方
它站在60的均线这里
继续往上面走
这是我们的一个买点
买入之后开始上涨
顺床涨之后
这里他没有形成死差
我们不卖
一直到这个地方
这里出现一个死差
就是我们的一个卖点
卖点之后
从这里大概是在13块14块钱左右
大概13块左右
然后到了这个位置
这个位置差不多有16块钱左右
16到15左右
那么一块多的一个收益
你就赚到手了
然后还有这么一个位置
他没有占到60均线胜风
但是如果你想尝试一下
风险打的比较高一点
如果你在这个地方买入
那么或许这么一大段行情
都是完全可以拿得住的
到这里又是一个卖点
好 那我们接下来再看一下其他的票
就这一支吧
这支票的这一段我们就没有必要去看
因为这一段它完全是在60小时均线下方在运行的
那我们看这一段
这一段它涨到60小时均线上方没有涨到的
而且往上面突破没有突破了
好 那么这个地方就是我们的一个买点
好 买点之后这个地方出现了一个死差
这是我们的一个卖点
好 这么一段收益我们也是吃了的
这么一段收益大概会有10%吧
应该会有
好 我们有仔细算
然后这么一段的话没有到我们严格的一个标准
就算是有盈利
我觉得大家也没有必要去做它
因为这一段利润不是属于我们这个正法的
大家一定要记住
你选择的某一个方向
那么一定要只找你这一个方向的
不要什么都想做
这么一段吃不到
当然是到了这里
又是一波行情
因为这里它刚好踩到
踩不到之后
它继续往下突破了
它突破之后
我们这个地方就可以买入
买入之后
这段利润可以吃得很舒服的
因为它基本没什么回调
一直吃一直吃一直吃
直到实现这个死差出现
这个死差出现的时候
我们这一大段行情是不是也吃到了
这一段行情知道
20%应该有吧
或者说30%可能都有
没有仔细算了
好
那我们再来看一支票
这支票的话
我们来找一下他的一个交易机会
这一段没有交易机会
好
这一段是有个小突破
这个小突破是个交易机会
然后买进去
继续
到这个地方卖出
好
这个地方就是卖出点
这个地方就是一个买点
到这里大概一个5%应该会有
好
然后到了这个地方
这是一个买点
好
这个买点之后
它一直在上面
这是一个横盘震荡的走势
这个横盘震荡走势
这里一直都没有出现一个标准死差
直到这里死差出现
那你大差不多在这个地方买
这个地方卖
这一笔那就是不胀不亏
这笔就是打平手了
这笔打平手之后
然后你大概看到这个地方
这个地方也的确是个买点
它继续往上突破了
然后马上打回去
也就是说这一段应该也是一个平手
或者说会有一点小亏
也就是说这种特别密集的这种走势
我们是不适合去做它的
然后一直这一段都没有什么行情
到这里开始有突破了
有突破了
站稳60小时均线没有
站稳了
然后这个地方那就可以是一个买点
好这里是一个买点之后我们一直走一直走一直到这个死刹出现好这一批又给赚回来大概10%应该会有好那我们再来看一支票就这一支这支票的话这一段是没有什么趋势的
到这里有
这里有个交易机会
然后买进去之后
这里是一个买点
买点买进去之后
这里死差出现死差出现
然后卖出差不多也有个5%
这里5%之后
然后这一段几乎没有了
然后到这一段也几乎没有
这一段又开始也出现一个买点
你还是站稳60小时均线
继续往上面走对不对
好还是继续往上面走的
那我们在这里一路一路是一路吃好吃到这
这又是一个卖点
这是一个卖点吃完之后后面的利润基本上也吃不到了
那么这一段差不多10%应该也会有
这就超短线的一个操作方式
那我们再来看一只吧
这一只的话就没什么看头了
这一只前面这一段没有任何交易机会给我们
他是全程下跌的支票
没有任何交易机会
这里出现了一个交易机会
这里出现一个交易之后
我们买入买入之后在这个地方卖出
在这个地方卖出的话不到40吧
就是就是40不到40
然后到这个位置
这个地方应该是不赚多少钱的
有可能是有可能会打个平
有可能小赚
但是亏的话应该不会亏
然后这里后面这一段没有回踩60均钱
所以它也不构成一个买点
这个支票的话它总是不够强势
所以我们还要记住一点的
就是我们选择票的话
要选择强势一点的票
我们再来看一支
这支的话不用讲了
这支没有任何交机会在里面
这支的话我们可以看一下
我们可以预演一下未来的走势
就比如说这支票
它现在是回踩到这个位置
对不对
好
那么其实在这个地方
我们是有一个买点的
在这么一个买点我们可以买进来
买进来之后
那么它后面的走势
如果是这个样子对吧
这个样子好一直走
那你就可以拉着
直到有一天死差出现
那你就卖出
然后如果跌破的话
那你也就止损
差不多就是这么一个格式来走
好我们再来看一支票
这支票是次行股
次行股没什么好看的
这个没意义
好这么一支票的话
这支票看看有没有交机会在里面
大家一起看一下
这段没有交机会
这段有一个交机会
对吧
这里有一个交机会
然后在这个地方买进
买进的话在个地方卖出
也有一小段利润
买了机会
然后在这里卖出这个地方的话
基本上就是没有利润
应该是个平
应该是个平手
好
然后到了这么一个地方
这个地方的话是一个买点
这个买点
然后它后面如果继续拉的话
那就是可以继续拉着
然后它后面如果跌破的话
那么这就说需要平仓
这还是一个自信股
没有看的意义
这个地方的话
这支票的话
它就是一个比较好的走势
好
然后在这个地方
这就是一个比较典型的买点
买点之后突破
好
突破这里是一个卖点
这里到了一个卖点的话
10%应该会有
然后这个地方其实也是一个买点
买点买进去之后
这一段利润你基本上可以吃完
吃完之后
然后就你死刹出现
死刹出现卖
这一段那你就可以吃到比较多的一个利润
然后这个地方
它没有回踩的不够有利润
但是你如果想要玩的风险大一点
也可以这么玩
然后今天也举了这么多个例子的
然后希望这些例子
大家也可以自己在盘后去找这么一些票
去测试一下
去回测一下
然后自己去抓住这些交易机会
好
那么本期视频就给大家讲到这里
如果觉得这个账法能对你的交易产生帮助
欢迎大家点赞转发家收藏